ah quel bonheur alors après je vous
partez de détails nommé Victor de la
musique carrière énorme vous avez chanté
avec Goldman et Rita Mitsouko aux
[__]
aussi trop de blabla je suis passé
complètement à côté parce que j'achète
en bagnole j'avais 14 ans déjà 88
[Rires]
j'avais 14 ans j'étais là je conduisais
ma petite Fiat droit de blague
les lois sont un petit peu plus jeunes
en voiture je suis passé complètement à
côté du fait que c'est une chanson
contre la violence cette femme ben oui
parce qu'en fait à l'époque à l'époque
donc j'étais avec un homme et une
foutait sur la gueule mais moi en tant
que mais si mais tu sais quand moi quand
tu me tapes je te tape si tu veux pas
mais donc j'avais pas l'impression que
c'est d'être une victime de violence
mais bon je me suis retrouvé quand même
avec des bleus des cocards des côtes
et vous portez pas plein de tous les pas
du tout moi ce qu'on faisait en faisait
des traquenards on a tendance chez lui
on va voilà quoi c'est ça
tu l'attends en bas de chez lui pour
leur frapper bien sûr
même une fois mes parents mon père et
mon oncle sont venus et non non le nom
attendu pour le raisonner le gars
n'était pas raisonnable donc non c'est
incroyable mais on régler ça entre nous
quoi il y avait pas d'autres
et tu as été tu as été frappé par des
hommes pas un seul
et à la pub tu mets des trucs très
touchante tu m'as dit ta sœur
non j'ai pas dit qu'elle en était mort
je dis que d'après moi enfin d'après moi
c'est pas d'après moi elle a quitté cet
homme et son n'est jamais remise et elle
est décédée mais il l'a frappait ah oui
terriblement c'est c'est en fait c'est
en écrivant ce texte enfin c'est parce
que je me suis rendu compte à cette
époque là que moi j'étais victime de
violent que ma petite sœur aussi que
j'avais des copilé et moi j'étais là
trop de blabla enfin j'avais envie de
leur dire mais elle est tous vous faire
[__] bien sûr tu vois j'ai pas une
question madame princesse c'est que
vous parlez de tout sans aucun tabou et
c'est super vous dites vous dites
notamment il y a un pamphlet qui est
sorti à manifeste dans lequel il affirme
une Richard dans lequel il y a vous et
tout ça et vous dites c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui actrice en France qu'on le
veuille ou non cité noir témoin payé et
vous aviez dit sur Camping Paradis et
franchement j'ai Jean-Luc Jean-Luc
Azoulay et vous en veux pas te parler il
m'a dit il y a aucun souci oui sur
Camping Paradis plus les années passées
moi on m'écrivez le texte je trouvais
pas de place et j’étais l'actrice la
moins payée parce que moi c'est vrai que
j'étais actrice la moins payée bon alors
mais je pense que c'est parce que
j'avais un mauvais agent qui avait mal
négocié
alors en plus tu vois c'était dans
l'émission à l'époque à mesure de cette
petite c'est celui qui te tire les vers
du nez que tu n'as pas tu vois bon bref
et en fait c'est j'avais fait quand même
une explique des explicative pour dire
pourquoi et tout et que je me sens mais
je leur ai dit je veux dire je suis allé
me plaindre c'est un truc qui était
interne moi j'en parle parce que j'ai
une grande gueule et je ferais des fois
mieux de la fermer mais j'en ai parlé
comme ça et ça a été accolé comme si
c'était parce que j'étais noir que
j'étais moi regardez vous dites dans le
Livre noir n'est pas un métier dans
lequel il y a Firmin Richard qui a fait
la crise euh première étoile qui
s'apparent vous euh c'est pas dans le
noir n'est pas bon il y a plein
d'actrices noires et faire une Richard
qui a jouécane dans la crise pardon
première étoile dit j'étais l'actrice la
moins payée parce que je suis noir elle
raconte ça pour huit femmes elle dit
j'étais la moins payée bon alors moi
j'ai pas dit que c'était parce que
j'étais noir mais il se trouve que c'est
quand même parallélisé tu vois donc je
dis ah bon après Jean-Luc c'est vrai que
moi Jean-Luc c'est mon gars sur t'adore
j'ai au téléphone mais c'est vrai et je
veux dire j'ai pas du tout et lui il se
mêle pas de ces trucs classés c'est pas
lui c'est pas qui mais vous êtes ajouté
pardon je coupe un peu parce que je
t'aime beaucoup mais vous avez même
rajouter on ne reconnaît pas même les
artistes noirs quand quand on David est
mort il y a pas une commémoration rien
alors ça m'a tué ça vous dites même les
joueurs n'existe pas mais c'est
d'ailleurs j'ai même interpellé la
ministre de la culture de l'époque était
Roselyne j'ai dit donc c'est quand quoi
qu'est-ce qui se passe parce que le gars
et c'est c'est notre culture populaire
aussi dont on parle et alors donc un
gars qui nous représente meurt
subitement en plus
alors donc tu dis rien
s'il te plaît donc c'est vrai que son
attaché de com est venu en DM dire oui
on a merdé excuse-moi